go back and look at my friend
and now friend of this show acclaimed
actor
comedian he's one of the funniest dudes
i know uh
o'shea jackson jr but for purposes of
this conversation
he is the the most hardcore laker fan
that i
know i don't know a die hard laker fan
and o'shea's twitter feed last night and
his instagram feed
had me dying first thing this morning
so what's up brother amen
talk your ish talk your ish right now
cause you was letting them
have it last night yeah you know
and to all the clipper fans out there
y'all can't really feel that bad i mean
this happens to y'all like
all the time so i'm sure you're used to
it i'm sure
it's just another drop in the bucket
i i really don't know like where
the disappointment could come from
because we've been telling y'all
all year that this was gonna happen to
you it wasn't a prediction
it was a spoiler and y'all chose not to
listen
like ugh tough break
listen how good do you feel right now
how good do you feel
you know i'm just i'm just and it's not
like
you know i went pretty hard last night
and i you know i i understand that the
lakers job
is not done it is far from over we
our whole motivation has been about
doing this for kobe
but man winning that city championship
last night felt amazing
and it felt so good because
you you guys got that celtic coach over
there
and he hyped all up to dis
you let him talk in to cover in our
banners defacing our statues
y'all don't even have a retired jersey
for me to
cover up and y'all trying to this
and then fraud george i mean paul george
uh he he ditched us the first go-around
and then kawhi you did this the second
go around and
quiet is kept the clippers are still
trash
oh look how annoying were they this year
to you
how annoying have they been how how much
have you been waiting for this because
you said y'all won the city championship
and y'all didn't even have to play it
y'all wonder what i wanted from home
y'all wanted from the couch
how good i mean you've been waiting for
this all year
plus a restart yeah it's uh
you know it's just it's just good it's
like you ever been
sitting at the house and you got a a
meal that you're about to get to and
then
you see that there's a fly in the
kitchen it's kind of like that
and then when you finally get up and you
get to whack that fly or in this case
the fly
lets itself out without you even having
to go near it
and you get to finally just enjoy your
meal you know that's what it feels like
and
it really would have been all good if
they wasn't trying to diss
us all year we don't even concern
ourselves with y'all
but y'all want to hang up billboards
la our way what's la yahweh
taking an uber early what la yahweh
we made like the lakers have have put so
much into the city of los angeles
and i know that the majority of these
fans
y'all weren't there for michael ola with
candy
y'all weren't there for eric piokowski
y'all weren't there so y'all are y'all
are people who used to have purple and
gold we went through a hardship
and then y'all jump ship so kick rocks
have la yo way we'd rather you have
anaheim your way
or seattle your way bakersfield even
lancaster anywhere
like the lakers like the sparks like the
kings
like the dodgers y'all just aren't it
and y'all are so
scared and so worthless that you have to
leave
staples center because you can't hang up
nothing
in staple center
oh shane would you wouldn't you rather
though oh [ __ ] wouldn't you rather just
play the clippers so then you could
sweep them or get them in five so you
even have more fun i mean
i know they just kind of
self-destructive but wouldn't it be fun
more fun
if you got a lakers clippers match-up
and you can see it
against the lakers let me tell you man
i play the clippers four times
a year and that's more than enough i
don't want nothing to do with these
dudes
my dad earlier said it's like
you got this dude who said he gonna
whoop you at three o'clock
and you show up at the spa at three and
heard he got beat up at 2 30.
like somebody else already whooped you
yeah y'all have no room to talk down the
lakers
the laker loyal the laker fans the bus
family y'all don't have y'all have no
history
besides being losers from now on
i want them to be the lost angelus
clippers
that's the one that's what we calling
them from now on the los
angeles clippers because that's all they
seem to do i have no time
i i mean this is i love you i love zubot
uh lou williams they had laker jerseys
on
we gave y'all those players and you have
no idea what to do with them
y'all are putting y'all faith in that
celtic coach whose only championship
is from beating the lakers who were
missing two or three starters that year
oh wait a minute now wait oh wait a
minute
oh see you coming down my street
now you're coming down my street here
what you do after that
hey you know 2010 2010 you know
kobe's last ring right right yeah i
remember right up three games
up three games to two you know uh
struggle
struggled in game seven it's all lakers
over here
and you got a laker hater leading that
team you know we was
it was really all good when they had you
know the chris paul thing is really what
set it off
because the lakers got cheated like no
other team has been cheated before
which is exactly the type of fuel a
laker fan needs
is to find out that that's never
happened before or
ever again and it only happened to us
david stern tried to say
rest in peace tried to say that they
don't want the big markets to take over
the league but just send them to the
exact same city
but even then that team was cool with
vinnie del negro was the coach and
they got blake and you know and that was
that was cool
but when y'all brought in doc doc drew a
line in the sand
and divided the city and after the
disrespect started having you you let
your owner turn
my locker room into his office you you
put
balloons and shirts on magic johnson's
statue how dare you
ain't no danny manning's statue uh and
then you cover up
not only the laker banners but the
sparks banners
the sparks got three in staple center
yup y'all have y'all even have three
retired jerseys
i used to go to clipper games and they
used to try and make me play if you sit
too close
i don't want to hear this they are done
done with me done with the [ __ ]
dude this is incredible i'm so glad you
shouted out pops earlier
because this is your no vaseline right
now this is what we're getting
live oh brother from another this is
you are crushing it listen did you you
know my man tj
the head of sports at twitter he had the
i think he had the best suite of
of all but man i'm pushing back he said
i'm pushing back my barbershop
appointment i can't trust any clippers
right now
i'm like i'm feeling that that that
that's that that's that's stuff that
makes your soul burn slow all that is
there's the jersey gold i say all i see
right there
sorry sorry this whole thing hey man you
got to tell us okay
you got to tell us what you uh what you
working on right now what you what you
happy about and proud of uh
in your professional life oh well right
now
um i'm working on a uh
a show for apple plus swagger
uh i'm a coach of this uh this aau team
is such a heavy story
uh it's a it's an episodic type series
um yeah that we're filming that over in
richmond virginia
we had to put a pause on things because
of the pandemic
but i can't wait to get back to that get
back to you know my kids
my my you know my team they uh there's
some hoopers there's some real hoopers
but they're also
killing it you know with the with their
acting chops and i just wanna
i gotta make sure my team is still sharp
when i see them you know
they were bringing it so tough uh
before we left and you know we just
gotta keep that exact same energy
we don't want to you know like we you
never want to lose
that fire that you had uh in the
beginning because then
it leads to nothing but a second round
exit to the denver nuggets
so you know you you definitely just want
to keep
you want to keep up that drive in that
fire and then uh after that
uh oh by the way that's produced by
kevin durant's shot to kd
yeah it should have been a lake yeah and
then we uh we're going into
new york to do a sneaker head film uh by
the name of american soul
that's produced by uh chris paul the one
that got away
and um uh uh kevin hart and it's with me
and pete davidson so
you know i'm excited sneakers and
basketball go
you know they go hand in hand like
clippers and losing so it's uh yeah it's
a very exciting time
possible no listen man i'm such a fan
but you know we go back man i'm just
really proud of you those are amazing
projects
not only am i excited to watch both
those projects
just the people you mentioned that
you're working with that you know in
sports who are now transitioning to
hollywood
i love to just be a fly on the wall when
y'all trash talking i love you
yeah you know what's going on
you already know i'm gonna give it to
them i can't i can't help it
you know my family we have a way with
words
but uh yes
that was my my action film and uh
you know i'm really excited about that
because they're going
from what i've read so far uh christian
good guys
the director and writer of the first one
he's going big he's going big on this
one
and if they could give me uh nine
damn fast and furious i could at least
get five dimmer thieves
for sure in the original
that's as i was gonna say before we get
you out of there out of here we want to
let you know
that it's been announced already you
know according to sources doc rivers is
coming back next year
to coach the clippers yes there's
another channel around
exit i love it
man great success i'm loved i love
that's great news man thank y'all
i'm gonna tell the homies hey thank you
doc
i you know i just want to just put it
out there
i love a black man with a successful job
but brother if you ever try to
disrespect my lakers again
i'mma be on your head that's just how it
is
i love my purple and gold right now yes
i'm enjoying the city title
you know you you win city and then you
go to nationals and that's where we
headed right now
and let me tell you if i win the
championship
i will go on a media tour like the world
has never seen
so i'll see you all again
we will come on back then we got to go
back come on back come on back after
this very interesting
conference finals or maybe come out
during the conference finals against the
nuggets
listen up before you mention doc i just
want to say one thing real quick though
because i'm not trying to be he's did we
lose him
yeah i'm not trying to be messy or
nothing like that
but that kind of came at your head he
ain't just going to lakers
didn't that go at you i mean i love doc
i love you but i'm just i mean i see
recall so this
that's where all this all this smoke is
coming from because you've been waiting
to give it to doc for a while if i
recall correctly
yeah because i've been i've been trying
to see he
what upsets him i'm sure is that i'm
trying to lift
the wool off of everyone's eyes you know
that i know his plan he's assaulted at
heart
his only ring got that three leaf clover
on it
and so i know he looks at it i know he
looks at it and he remembers the days
so he's a celtic at heart and y'all let
this celtic come in here
and let y'all disrespect the lakers the
team that has been holding the city down
for
decades and y'all are confused clipper
fans
y'all y'all are being poisoned and i
will
cure this this virus that has taken over
los
angeles oh and i'll do it for the purple
and gold
kobe be with us all michael smith
oh absolutely absolutely and i know how
much you love the mamba
please let us get a laker celtics finals
so i i just want as much o'shea as i
could get for the rest of the nba season
this series and the finals please let us
get it so you can come back and do this
again man
this is great let me tell you bro this
is the kobe path this whole time
kobe's his his toughest opponent for
that first ring
was the blazers got rid of them the the
coach
that was there when he tore his achilles
we beat him so bad
he just quit the next day mike d'antoni
is out of here
and then you look the last time the
lakers
played the denver nuggets in the western
conference finals
the lakers won the championship in
orlando
and so what's the way to top it all off
the celtics kobe's last ring this is for
the mamba
everybody know it it's time for us to
show it
that's what's up o'shea jackson jr
ladies and gentlemen that was fun
appreciate you bro fantastic thank you
all right appreciate you man it's all
downhill from there that was
going to talk about it clifford jokes
are almost out
not in fact
you